Now that you have trained
your first model.
There is something very
important I want to discuss.
You might have seen in the assignment
that we had a training set
as well as a validation set and
a test set.
What is that all about?
Don't skip that part, it has to do
with measuring how well you're doing,
without accidentally shooting
yourself in the foot.
And it is a lot more subtle
than you might initially think.
It's also very important because as
we'll discover later, once you know how
to measure your performance on a problem
you've already solved half of it.
Let me explain why measuring
performance is subtle.
Let's go back to our
classification task.
You've got a whole lot
of images with labels.
You could say, okay, I'm going to run
my classifier on those images and
see how many I got right.
That's my error measure, and then you
go out and use your classifier on new
images, images that you've
never seen in the past.
And you measure how many you get right,
and
your performance gets worse,
the classifier doesn't do as well.
So what happened?
Well imagine I construct a classifier
that simply compares the new image to
any of the other images that I've
already seen in my training set, and
just return the label.
By the measure we defined earlier,
it's a great classifier.
It would get 100% accuracy
on the training sets.
But as soon as it sees a new image
it's lost, it has no idea what to do.
It's not a great classifier.
The problem is that your classifier
has memorized the training set and
it fails to generalize to new examples.
It's not just a theoretical problem.
Every classifier that you will
build will tend to try and
memorize the training sets.
And it will usually do that very,
very well.
Your job, though, is to help it
generalize to new data instead.
So, how do we measure
the generalization instead of measuring
how well the classifier
memorized the data?
The simplest way is to take a small
subset of the training set.
Not use it in training and
measure the error on that test data.
Problem solved,
now your classifier cannot cheat
because it never sees the test data so
it can't memorize it.
But there is still a problem because
training a classifier is usually
a process of trial and error.
You try a classifier,
you measure its performance, and
then you try another one,
and you measure again.
And another, and another.
You tweak the model, you explore
the parameters, you measure, and
finally, you have what you think
is the prefect classifier.
And then after all this care you've
taken to separate your test data from
your training data and only measuring
your performance on the test data,
now you deploy your system in
a real production environment.
And you get more data.
And you score your performance
on that new data, and
it doesn't do nearly as well.
What can possibly have happened?
What happened is that your
classifier has seen your test data
indirectly through your own eyes.
Every time you made a decision about
which classifier to use, which parameter
to tune, you actually gave information
to your classifier about the test set.
Just a tiny bit, but it adds up.
So over time, as you run many and
many experiments, your test data
bleeds into your training data.
So what can you do?
There are many ways to deal with this.
I'll give you the simplest one.
Take another chunk of your training
sets and hide it under a rock.
Never look at it until you
have made your final decision.
You can use your validation set
to measure your actual error and
maybe the validation set will
bleed into the training set.
But that's okay because you're
always have this test set
that you can rely on to actually
measure your real performance